the jurogan experience i got a text from
pete's brat the og that's why and pete
spratt
let me know about your background like i
did not know
you were a fighter pilot i did not know
that you
did you work at area 51 i cannot confirm
or deny that
i worked at nellis air force base which
is okay in that general vicinity
so so you can't talk about like
experimental [ __ ] or anything like that
you know what i did the first thing i
did
at nellis was when i flew into
thunderbirds right and then i went away
for a couple assignments and then when i
came back i was an aggressor
and if you remember the movie top gun
you know viper and all those guys were
in the camouflage planes they
acted as the enemy forces and trained
blue forces before they go off to combat
that's what i did the second time around
so
the nellis ranges are probably up in
that general vicinity
but as far as being someone that worked
at that now i worked at nellis air force
base
oh we flew in that okay in that general
area i don't believe you i think you're
lying
now now i think you're holding back did
you feel it jamie
all of a sudden he's like smiling i
don't know the answers of the question
you guys don't want guys in dark suits
and shades to come in here and
be like uh mr smith we needed i already
talked to those dudes
they're good guys they're just trying to
protect us from the aliens you know the
crazy thing is
in that area when people used to think
they would see ufos and stuff like that
you know there's a book that came out
a couple years ago called red eagles
that explained a lot of that stuff going
on and what they thought
were ufos or you know transportation
planes that were landing at some of the
bases and stuff up there yeah a lot of
people see wacky [ __ ] yeah the first
time i ever saw a stealth bomber i was
uh i was filming fear factor in
um palmdale which is uh
near was it edwards uh right by edwards
yeah and
i saw a stealth bomber flying overhead i
swear to god i thought it was darth
vader
when you see one of those things in real
life you would think especially if you
didn't know
that the united states was developing
one of those like when they were first
developing them and flying them before
they
made it public that thing looks like
it's from another world so
as part of you say that so when i was on
thunderbirds we do incentivize
like media personalities and other
people and i was out at our
training area which is over death valley
and we're talking to the navy
controllers
and they come over and say you know i
was thunderbird too t-bird two i need
you to fly straight and level for five
minutes so there's gonna be aircraft off
your nose i need you to you know
diverge to the right and stay away from
it i'm like what in the world is this so
i threw my radar out there which should
snag
anything out there and i'm getting these
intermittent hits
and i go i don't see anything on the
radar next thing you know i look up and
i go what the
[ __ ] has happened and i look up and it's
a b2 that has you know an escort plane
right next to it that comes right next
to
i looked at it for the first time and i
go there's they're aliens out here this
is some kind of space
that thing yeah i mean look at that that
does not look like it's from here
yep that absolutely looks like it's from
another world
yeah like all those when people talk
about seeing those triangular
spacecrafts in the sky
i mean maybe some of them are from
another planet
yeah so if you've never seen one of
those and like for me as a pilot
perspective i've never seen anything
like that
you know you hear about the f-117 from
the gulf war and
you see this big thing coming towards
you and that's what everybody always
reports too
a triangular object with like a light on
each corner i mean that is a stealth
bomber
yep that's a crazy looking aircraft man
yeah so i had somebody in my back seat
that was like oh my god what is that
what is that thing coming by i mean if
we thought that we were being invaded
and then you saw things like that flying
overhead
that that is what i would imagine they
would be flying they came from another
planet that thing is out at whiteman air
force base
you know you see it flying out there all
the time so there are folks here in the
local area there to see it taking off
are there some new ones that they
haven't released yet i don't know so i
retired about eight years ago
right i heard a crazy story one day that
someone was hunting
up in montana and saw something similar
to that that
he had never seen before that like came
out of the ground in like a vertical
type thing and then took off
which you know the f-35 and planes like
that will take off some of them in a
vertical stance
and then go forward but to see something
that size and that scale do something
like that
it kind of makes me wish i was still in
the military just so you could be in the
know
that's right what so which one can do
that and take off
the f-35 yeah so there's a couple
variants um so the air force one does
traditional
rolling takeoff but the marine one you
know it's almost like a harrier
so the the back engine will rotate so
it'll take off vertical
and then as it's going forward the
engine will rotate back the other way to
give it forward propulsion
but man just technology wise the stuff
that we're flying now so i will tell you
this
the first time i fought on the range
against the f-22 raptor
and i've fought against everything in
the world so out of nellis with the
aggressors everybody comes there to
train to get prepared for combat there's
no better plane in the world than the
f-22
when that thing passed me and some of
the stuff that i saw i could do
i go there's no better plane in the
world so as far as air superiority
f22 is at the top of the food chain what
is the difference it's
f-22 is primarily air superiority you
know so like air-to-air dog fighting
long-range short-range missiles
uh f-35 is you know a command and
control platform it still has weapons on
it can drop bombs shoot missiles etc
but the role is a little bit different
so yeah that's the f-22 you go to an air
show and see that thing
you're like is that a plane or a
helicopter with some of the stuff that
it does but fighting against that
you know as a fighter pilot your average
fighter pilot is the cockiest person
that you would ever meet in the world
just like top gun
exactly that's all real we're better
than everybody that's our philosophy
but it's very happy to have that
philosophy all right i mean look at that
look at that that's insane
oh my god that's insane it just shoots
straight up in the sky
oh my god i mean it doesn't even look
like a real
a real plane that that is a mean machine
right there so i got friends that fly
that plane and you know you see it
hey it's designed in combat you know the
united states is still going to be at
top of the food chain as far as the
personnel that we have the men and women
that fly these airplanes and then the
equipment that we're flying
you're not going to find anything to
match it that's incredible that turn
that it just made in the sky
so is that what the the maneuverability
of it is that what's superior
what the [ __ ] that's insane
so thrust factoring on the back you know
plus the flight controls i mean look he
just flat plated that
and wow the amount of thrust is coming
out of it so you know internal avionics
the stealth capability and the
maneuverability of it
nothing in the world is going to be that
but they can't fly very long right
you know uh it's it's a total package
so whenever you go to combat or
something you're going to have tanker
support out there so you're going to
meet a
you know air refueler up at 20 000 feet
and get gas nothing can carry external
fuel tanks
but the goal is to be able to plan a
mission to be able to go in escort
have guys drop your bombs or do whatever
and get back out with tanker support
you know there's always that philosophy
without the gas you know no one is going
to go so like when i was in iraq and
stuff we take off in saudi arabia
fly an hour up meet a tanker go fly a
five hour mission
come back to the tanker get more gas go
out and fly for another couple hours and
then go back to the base
how long can that fly for you know i
don't know it obviously depends on how
hard you got the gas down right i think
in the f-16
if we stayed in full after burner for
you know
five minutes you probably run out of gas
five minutes
or it could be quicker than that now the
goal is endurance you obviously want to
be able to stay out there to maintain
the
yeah you know go the length of your
mission um
but you look at the length of the
mission and fuel capacity and the goal
is obviously to have somebody there as a
backup because you never want to be out
there by yourself you always want to
have that support
you know so you may have guys that are
sitting back here in a cap
waiting for their turn to come in you
run out of gas up front now you swap out
those guys come back in so total
protection so until they come up with
something superior to internal
combustion engines we're always going to
be limited by
the amount of fuel they can carry just
because of the weight right
so as far as endurance yes now
capabilities are the plane
most fighter planes have a g capability
of nine g's and actually you know times
a
force of gravity do you wear a g-suit we
did wear g-suits so in a fourth
generation like a f-15
f-16 is a fourth generation fighter we
wore g-suits on
the abdomen and down on the legs and
basically what that does as you pull g's
you're going against gravity
and blood starts to drain from your
brain down into your lower extremities
so the g suit is just a capability to
help counter it it's really
a tightening restriction of your muscles
starting with your calves
hamstrings buttocks all the way up and
we do the hooking
yeah the hook you hook and that's really
to hold the oxygen in
and what that does is lock everything
down to hopefully hold the blood
up in your brain as long as possible i
told you i flew with the blue angels
once and when i did that i
i got to seven and a half g's before i
couldn't take it anymore
so did you start to gray out or yeah
tunnel vision yeah it was like an
elevator door was closing yeah
and you know i'm doing that so it's
weird
because people think it's you know two
g's
would be one greater than one three g's
is one greater than two but when you
start to get above five
it's not a plus one it's exponential oh
so when you start to get to seven so six
is ten
oh yeah that's what it feels like and
you can't explain how it feels but nine
g's is absolutely
i mean you get back home that night from
straining and everything you know
measles what it looks like little
we call them jesus where your blood
vessels will actually start to pop
oh wow and you get these little specks
on from straining so hard that you're
popping blood vessels
but the goal is obviously not to fall
asleep we call it fall asleep in
airplane glu uh
yes of consciousness uh g-lock is what
it's called if you do that and you're in
the air
it may take you 30 seconds to a minute
to be able to come back to any kind of
capacity
and if that happens you know the
majority of time is going to be
catastrophic
i uh made it through that and then i
blacked out on the way back
because i didn't hook on the way back
because i thought i got cocky
i thought we're good and we made a hard
turn and i think i blacked out at like
five
like four and a half or five it wasn't
even that much compared to seven and a
half
yeah if you're not ready at four you
know people are like oh i can do g's you
get on a roller coaster that's like
a half a g or one g i blacked out
exponentially and i threw up
it was double embarrassing did they make
you wear a g suit no no g suit see the
reason they don't wear a g-suit
is because in close formation
if you wear a g-suit the g-suit is going
to fill with air to help with that
restriction on your legs
and in the f-18 they have a center
control stick and they rest their arm
on their right leg and if that g suit is
moving up and down it's going to move
your control stick
so the f-16 has a side stick controller
where it doesn't touch your leg at all i
mean it's like
you recline back in the seat and the
side stick controller so we can wear a
g-suit so it won't affect
precision you know moving your arm back
and forth is there any other technology
that they've invented to deal with
gravity
like that just the sheer force of the
acceleration so not just a g-suit
but you will have uh induced pressure
breathing you know so you wear a
specific kind of oxygen mask
and that's gonna force air into your
system because the one thing you would
hate to do is just hold your breath it's
like a three second count you know you
do that hook and then it's a three
second count
exhale inhale right quick and as part of
that pressure breathing
would you exhale and open your mouth
it's going to force air back in with
that pressure breathing system
so with the two of those together and
then we combine it with you got to be in
shape
you know you got to lift weights you got
to have some kind of cardio conditioning
to be able to last because it's one
thing to be strong enough to hold
that you know g position but then you do
a 45 minute
you know dog fighting mission your
body's going to get tired so you got to
be able to sustain that the entire time
so most fighter pilots are going to lift
weights they're going to do you know
extreme cardio exercises to be able to
sustain
but anything else other than that it was
kind of weird back in the day
it would be go drink a coke and a bag of
doritos and get that sugar rust for that
45-minute flight and be able to sustain
through it
really it's more of a health conscious
thing now you know the total package
staying in shape
i guess they're just smarter now about
it probably a lot the blue angel guy
that i flew with was a tank
and the dude was swole he was like
joelle romero he was jacked
you know that was philosophy because
when i was on the team i'm six one i
probably weighed 230 to 35 that's large
for a fighter pilot right the
the cockpit was extremely tight usually
they're smaller guys because
is that a thing with the the the gravity
it's easier to sustain gravity
it is a it's a height limitation so you
can't be so tall
when your head is up against the top of
the canopy oh that's all it is but you
also can't be that short where you can't
see over the dashboard
but there's a weight limitation too you
know you can't be below a minimum weight
because if you ever had to eject
and you're below let's say 125 pounds
that parachute is going to drag you you
won't be able to stop
uh or if you're above you know whatever
the weight is 250 265
you're going to come down in that
parachute pretty hard and you're
probably going to get hurt yeah they
can't make custom [ __ ] for you
nope no and it's the same basic fighter
so the thunderbirds
it's a you know it's a frontline fighter
that they take someone they take the gun
out and they put a smoke barrel in it
but it's the same basic avionics the
same basic controls and it's just
painted red white and blue
and all the professionals that are the
maintenance guys for the thunderbirds
the best in the world the finest in the
world and i had four of the finance when
i was on the team
they take them off of active duty lines
and bring them nellis air force base and
do all the stuff on the planes but
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other
apps and can download episodes to save
on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience